[Applause]
special night it is our this is our last
show before next year we come back
January 18th that's two months so thank
you for appreciate that but I this has
been an amazing season I want to thank
my producers my crew my head writer
Donald Trump
I'm sorry to leave you at the two buds
but I need a break from mother [ __ ] I
mean this has been very stressful ten
months of him this is the time of year
when I make the transition from medical
marijuana to recreational but you know
Trump is gonna be here tomorrow he's
coming to California to check
well you know checking on the wildfire
situation and he says he can relate
because last Tuesday he also lost a
house
like this is what we're going through
here in this date this is very serious
really serious [ __ ] if you have seen
what's going on and some people have
been affected we have at this show I
read in the paper today they said human
beings were probably responsible for the
fires there goes my theory that it was
freebasing raccoons of course Trump's
response you saw that was to blame the
victims threatened to withhold federal
funds this is what he does every time
there's a disaster wildfires mismanage
of forests mass shooting you should have
been armed you know hurricane your
island is very inconveniently located
its response to every tragedy is how can
i hurt
he is too empathy what food courts are
to ambience that's
and today he today he went out of his
way to say he's coming here just for the
firefighters doesn't want to give the
impression that he gives a [ __ ] about
the citizens of this state who didn't
vote for him he only once came here
before you know that too to look at wall
swatches he went down to the border to
see what wall the wall he still hasn't
built you know by the way Trump fans and
others if you're keeping score no wall
no health care plan that was better
cheaper covered everybody know but the
trade deficit bigger bigger the tax cut
did not pay for itself the debt of
course is exploding North Korea building
bombs again you know mr. president you
can only slide so long on charm at some
points but actually now I have to say
today there is in the news this is a
pretty big story something he is
actually behind once in a while he
stumbles upon the right thing a
bipartisan prison reform bill that's
going to address the Deponia and three
strikes laws mandatory sentences to some
reason Trump suddenly has taken an
interest in
yeah
today he made a fool of himself saying
he answered by myself nobody helped me
with these answers the written questions
from Robert Muller he said it took a
little longer than usual because he's
not used to lying and writing and you
know the word now from why shouldn't
everybody sing reporting this that he's
apparently literally depressed he he's
barely barely touching his nightly
chicken bucket and he should be the prey
should be worried I mean everybody has
skeletons in their closet he has mass
graves I mean House Democrats have been
spotted at Costco buying subpoenas in
bulk a lot of things but this is cuz he
lost the election that's why he's
depressed now they have the subpoena
power Trump had by the way but the
election Trump has a theory that he gave
us yesterday about voter fraud he said
oh my god I can't believe we have to
actually talk about what this guy says
this bothers me so much anyway
he's a spoiled five-year-old and where
the man his mother brought home from the
bar so we have to we have to pretend
that to talk about this step okay so he
says that people with no right to vote
sometimes get this go to their car put
on a different hat and a different shirt
and come in and vote again I it sounds
like an episode of The Brady Bunch
right but you know what let's end on a
happy note newly elected Democrats they
had their orientation who saw a lot more
diverse thirty four new women
[Music]
the Republican Republican side all white
all straight one-woman party of Lincoln
party of sausage
you